[Music]
[Applause]
right we wanted to check in on the
temperature with the Dallas Cowboys Bob
Sturm the uh Hardline talk show host
he's been there for a long time the
ticket afternoon drive from 3:00 to 7:
Bob kind enough to join us how's morale
there in Dallas Bob after the news that
Mike McCarthy is coming
back well luckily we practice this just
about every year Dan so we're good at
this uh we've been here before we've
seen this episode so uh uh I I can't say
that the most shocking performance
possibly in cowboys history was that big
of a shock if you look at it that way
okay with what Mike said yesterday did
that increase confidence uh add more
questions he sounded a little bit more
confident or you know there was a
direction that he was going in that
almost like hey I'm My Own man and I'm
I'm going to get us past this threshold
yeah there's some Defiance to it for
sure because uh he takes the the slings
and arrows like very few other coaches
uh you know I think he has a very
comparable resume to a lot of guys who
have way better marketing departments uh
around the NFL and I I realize being a
defender of Mike McCarthy's career uh
today seems like a a lonely post for me
to be on but uh he's done a very good
job as an NFL coach and he's done a very
good job as coach of the Dallas Cowboys
and yet to most if not all it doesn't
matter and any of the words yesterday
were like uh everyone you know everyone
just has deflector shields on because
they are convinced he's not the one to
lead them to the promised land and you
know again around and around we go it's
it's over 10,000 days since Super Bowl
30 Dan and uh the natives don't want to
hear the reasons they got bounced uh by
the youngest team in in NFL history in
the Wild Card round at home when it
appeared their Road was wide open to at
least get to the NFC title game do we
know if Jerry Jones reached out to
anybody well we I don't that's a great
question for Jane uh I I don't I don't
know but my general takeaway Dan is is
this uh I suspect they did but I also
think there is a group of candidates
that would be a clear upgrade from Mike
McCarthy who have no interest in working
here and I I think that's been the theme
for decades and it's been uh because of
the circumstances Jerry Jones has set up
uh partly to uh make sure everything
revolves around him at all times and
we've we've normalized it here in Dallas
like everybody's just accepted like you
know the Sun comes out every morning it
goes away every afternoon and Jerry's
going to keep doing what Jerry wants to
do and there's nothing we can do to
change any of those three things uh but
in you know I I don't think Jim Harbaugh
would come here I don't think Bill bich
would come here and so when you look at
what does that leave you with Mike Vel
Mike Zimmer whatever Jerry would come up
with I don't know that even he can
convince himself that's a better option
than Mike
McCarthy if you said to the fans you can
have a vote on changing your quarterback
changing your coach or changing
ownership wow that's an amazing uh boy
that's that's a good one Dan I would I
personally would think I would like to
try a new
owner I've been I've been around the
block enough times here to say uh I I
feel like the next quarterback is going
to have a bigger burden than Dak does
and Dak has a bigger one than Romo had
and and as far as coach McCarthy Garrett
Wade Phillips bill parcel's just keep
going down the list we've tried to
switch those guys out we've seen almost
no difference in the results so let's
try the guy who uh seems to you know
have the world you know revolve around
him so so I I think a day will come when
Jerry Jones is no longer running this
thing I think his son will see it in a
slightly different way but who could say
uh we're we're we're we're reaching
around in the dark here Dan to try to
find the the the solution to what makes
no sense to anyone around here with the
Cowboys uh since 1995 are the Cowboys
planning on losing their defensive
coordinator Dan Quinn well that's a
great one too I mean as you said
everything on Sunday morning was one way
and then by Sunday night it was a
different way and Sunday morning Dan
Quinn was one of the hottest coaching
prospects out there and by uh Sunday
night everybody's like how do you sell
this to your public that the same guy
that gave up 283 to Tom Brady and the
Patriots in the Super Bowl has now
turned around and made the Green Bay
Packers look like the most Unstoppable
offense in NFL history when Jordan love
is making his very first NFL start as a
more than a touchdown Underdog how is
that even possible and and everybody
goes back to well it might be because he
plays safeties as linebackers and they
just get rolled over in the Run game by
the ners by the bills to an extent by
the Dolphins and the Lions but
absolutely the Packers just looked at
the bills and 49ers tape and said
they've got the same linebackers out
there let's do the same thing and and
and the the Cowboys were absolutely
powerless to do anything about it
if I talk to you in a year from now Bob
what's the topic of conversation in
Dallas well I assume um it will be a new
coach I I don't really have any other
way to to you know measure the end of
his contract with the expectations here
and the expectations here is we have to
figure out a way to get back to at least
the final four if not the Super Bowl uh
now if the Lions do it now you're just
talking about two franchises in the NFC
with a drought this long the Cowboys and
Washington uh it used to be three uh
Detroit will never get there well
Detroit is actually one game away from
getting there and so the list gets even
smaller um you know Jerry's getting
older uh the patience is getting shorter
I guess but uh but that's the weird
thing about Jerry he never seems to fire
a guy in a fit of rage uh for all of his
for all of you know his attributes that
are that are well reviewed um you know
at least we can say he waited way too
long on Garrett and maybe he's waiting
way too long on McCarthy who can say at
this point but with one year left on his
deal the idea that the expectations will
go up but the ability to have as good a
roster will go down competition will
certainly get better I assume they're
finding a new head coach which would
lead people back to well why don't they
just do that right now great to talk to
you Bob thanks for joining us always a
pleasure Dan that's Bob Stern the uh
Hardline talk show host on the ticket in
Dallas weekdays from 3: until 7: local
time